>> So at the beginning of this lesson I
joked with Matt that he was reading the first book
in the Game of Thrones series. But imagine that this
book instead was filled with the entire human genome sequence.
>> Wow I know that's a lot of letters, but so is the first book
in the Game of Thrones series. I think it has like 300,000 words in it.
>> Well, let's say on average each word has about five letters give or take.
>> Okay.
>> And the human genome sequence has 3 billion letters.
How many books do you think it would take to
fill the entire 3 billion letter human genome sequence? Just
one genome. Now don't worry if you don't know the
exact math or the exact number, but give me an estimate.